réglez les caméras vérifier les costumes
des acteurs une scène révoltante de 1832
est en train de se jouer ici à
l'habitation de base
un jeune esclave est accusée injustement
d'avoir incendié une habitation mais un
ange gardien qui permet d'échapper à son
triste sort on se demande à chaque fois
qu'on crée une nouvelle histoire on dit
qu'est ce qui justifie la présence d'un
ange gardien qui a besoin d' aide qui
est forcément quelque chose de leur de
l'injustice ou quelque chose de très
fort que joséphine va aider et en fait
lors d'un déjeuner on s'est dit il faut
absolument qu'on aille en martinique et
ça a correspondu à une envie de l'auteur
qui voulait depuis longtemps parler de
l'esclavagé plus de 20 ans que la série
joséphine ange gardien met en lumière
des questions dramatique
cette fois il s'agit de l' esclavage une
scène tout l'espace jeunes acteurs
indifférent c'est vraiment triste
franchement j'ai failli pleurer quand
jours sans faire exprès mais ouais c'est
grave quand même désir que juste parce
que je suis noir juste la couleur
séparables si j'ai rien fait ou juste
parce que je suis noir
quant à l'actrice mimie mathy elle porte
sur cette période
un regard beaucoup plus générale c'est
très très très touchant de savoir
surtout que c'est de sa part d'histoire
vrai que cette période a existé
avec des hommes complètement fou qui en
un service et d'autre c'est un fléau qui
ont connu beaucoup de pays et que
connaissent encore certains pays et ça
n'aurait jamais dû exister
d'ailleurs le tournage de cet épisode
aura nécessité une écriture un peu
particulière l'objectif était d'être le
plus juste possible par rapport à
l'histoire et de ne pas tronqué de ne
pas faire changer les choses et de ne
pas trop aller dans un sens de d'une
écriture facile donc on a on a fait
travailler les scénaristes dans ce sens
pour que les prises d'informations ici
sur les locaux sur les plus justes et
servent le servent le récit le tournage
de cet épisode de joséphine ange gardien
a fait l'effet d'un petit miracle dans
le monde du cinéma local
une dizaine d'acteurs de figurants mais
également une vingtaine de techniciens
ont dû être recrutés